when I was 12 I was here all night asked
if I could give any advice
[Music]
hi I'm Eddie whoo I'm a high school
mathematics teacher and I've also the
host of teenage boss on the ABC when I
was 12 I was expected to be a good
well-behaved boy who did really well at
school if I could give advice to my 12
year old self it would be take your time
you know you've got this opportunity in
front of you where in this country you
have access to education to people to
opportunities that you don't need to
rush through I think when I was 12 I was
really anxious to be the very best
person that I could be and work out who
that was supposed to be in a way that
was liked and that was really hard for
me because I didn't I didn't wasn't a
big or strong or athletic person the
kinds of things that so many people
valued and I felt like okay I don't know
if the person who I am is what people
actually like but you know what
everyone's unique and I think I would
say my 12 year old self you're something
special and different to everyone else
around you and that's totally okay when
I think about what it means to be a man
I think what I've come to understand is
that it's about courageously loving and
serving that people around you with the
gifts that you have true manhood looks
like being focused on others and being
able to say hey you know what there's a
need that others have that I can I can
assist with the top tips I'd give to
boys today are know that you're headed
somewhere you're going into the future
you're becoming something it's really
easy to make decisions just on the basis
of how does it feel right now what does
it get me in this short term but
actually it's super important and
something we've always consciously have
to do because it's not always our nature
to think about well what's this going to
lead to what will the consequences being
what kind of a person will I become if
this is what I do with my life think
about where you're headed
think about the trajectory that you're
on and make sure that you take on
actions that with all the knowledge that
you have and all the understanding you
have in your situation
head you somewhere that you'd be proud
to say yeah this is someone I want to be
this is a place I want to go
I think 12-year old Eddie would barely
be able to recognize Eddie today 12-year
old Eddie was was a timid bookish person
and you know afraid to speak to people
and in many ways I sometimes still feel
there's impulses but I've learned that
you know what there's a wonderful world
of people out there and I think that
12-yard Eddie would have um I'm pretty
surprised to see the career choices that
I made and the ways that I've actually
been able to help and serve the people
around me in ways that would have been
impossible for 12-yard 82 even imagine
[Music]